antes de que continúe quiero
introducirlos a lo que podría ser un
concepto no tan familiar esto más bien
viene de la química que a lo mejor
puedes ya conocer un poco y es el mol
esto no es nada que te crezca en la
cabeza ni en la cara ni ningún animal
que haga hoyos pero los moles estamos
hablando de una unidad llamada mol baja
que sólo un número es como decir decir
moles como decirnos un número de algo
por ejemplo una docena es como decir una
docena de huevos digamos una docena de
huevos son 12 12 huevos no justo como
eso un bol de algo podría ser éste es
justamente 6.0 23 o algo de ese estilo
es que los 6.0 23 por 10 a la 23 ok
déjenme déjenme buscar el número exacto
porque ya llamé ya estoy desconfiando de
mí mismo entonces déjenme lo buscó por
aquí
el mol es 6.0 22 por 10 a la 23 de algo
ok entonces está muy cerquita solo que
es 6.0 22 por 10 a la 23 ok entonces
déjenme déjenme corregir esto es 6.0 22
entonces digo nunca pedimos un molde de
huevos entonces no creo que en la
historia se haya producido tanta
cantidad de huevos pero este número es
muy muy muy muy grande donde se usa
bueno un molde es usado realmente para
contar átomos así que lo que un molde de
átomos o de moléculas es son 6.0 22 x 10
a la 23 moléculas átomos es un número
muy grande y lo que es interesante de un
mol es es la masa ok entonces digamos
que la masa de algo su masa en gramos
tenemos que un modo por ejemplo de
carbón o de carbón o su masa en gramos
es igual es igual
su masa en gramos de carbono entonces
bajo está bajo esta idea la masa
ok digamos que sí tenemos x gramos vamos
a tener una masa de x gramos donde x es
el la masa atómica de un átomo de
carbono
la masa atómica del del átomo de carbono
de lo que estamos hablando ok entonces
la masa atómica la masa atómica es lo
que nos va a dar está íntimamente
relacionado con un entonces déjenme
sacar de la página de una página porque
ya les mostré donde estoy sacando
algunas cosas pero bueno voy a buscar en
google alguna tabla periódica para que
veamos un ejemplo vamos a ver si podemos
encontrar alguna buena
esta se ve bien
veamos
pues
creo que
creo que esta está bastante bien
tenemos una tabla periódica de elementos
vemos que podemos hacer
entonces si nos vamos al carbono que
está justo aquí podemos ver que es un
número atómico es 6 y que el número de
protones ese es el número de protones
que tiene ok y abrimos nos da más
información de esto entonces el número
de masa atómica es la masa del átomo de
carbono completo ok pero la mayoría de
la masa de un átomo es a partir de los
protones y los neutrones los neutrones
son los productos y los protones pesan
más o menos lo mismo sin embargo los
electrones son mucho mucho más pequeños
ok entonces realmente no aportan mucho a
la masa del átomo así que si quieres
saber la masa de este de este átomo
simplemente tienes que sumar la de los
protones y neutrones así que en promedio
la mayoría de los átomos tienen más o
menos el mismo número de protones y
neutrones digo algunos tienen por
ejemplo el carbono tiene 7 neutrones oa
veces tiene 5 oa veces 6 y esos de hecho
se llaman isótopos no voy a adentrarme
más en eso solo es el mito mismo átomo
con distinto número de neutrones
por eso en general la masa atómica más o
menos es igual a la masa de protones y
de neutrones y como tienden a ser
iguales entonces el número atómico por
ejemplo si es 6 la masa más o menos va a
ser 12 ahora para qué es esto útil
entonces podemos decir que si tenemos
aquí por ejemplo el galio ok tengo un
molde galio ok ok bueno tenemos aquí el
niobio digamos que si tengo un molde
niobio y vemos aquí en la tabla
periódica tiene un número atómico de 41
este es el número de átomos que tiene
perdón de protones entonces en promedio
de todos los isótopos que puede tener
tiene una masa de 92.9 digamos 93
entonces de hecho es un poquito más que
el doble del número atómico pero digamos
nos quedamos con el 93 si tenemos un
molde en mi obvio tenemos 6.0 22 por 10
a la 23 átomos de niobio tendría una
masa de
una masa de 92 gramos eso es bastante
fácil o que simplemente miramos al átomo
al elemento digamos el cromo el cromo si
tenemos una masa atómica que es más o
menos de 52 y vemos esto aquí si tengo
un molde cromo es decir 6 por 10 a la 23
de ellos eso va a tener una masa de 52
gramos
así es como pensamos aún muy y de y
déjenme decirles
que por ejemplo el mol un molde de una
molécula nos da una cantidad de cuánto
tiene esa esa sustancia digamos pero con
esto dicho podemos decir también la masa
verdad inmediatamente y esto va a tener
una gran implicación en termodinámica
vamos a borrar todo esto entonces
dijimos en en el pasa en los pasados
vídeos que la presión que la presión por
el volumen es igual a o es proporcional
es decir es igual a multiplicar una
constante ya veremos cuál es esa
constante especial a la energía cinética
total total del sistema y también
dijimos que esto es proporcional digamos
ajá es proporcional es decir es
multiplicar por una constante ésta es
otra constante por supuesto al número de
moléculas
el número de moléculas que tenemos por
la temperatura ok porque vimos que la
temperatura es como más o menos la
energía cinética por por molécula
entonces en general podríamos decir que
la presión por el volumen es
proporcional es decir es multiplicar por
una constante que vamos a llamar r ya
veremos de dónde viene eso en un momento
es proporcional a esta constante por el
número de moléculas n
ok a quito métodos este el número de
moléculas pero aquí estoy poniendo estoy
contando en moles
si tienes uno eso quiere decir que tengo
6.0 22 por 10 a la 23 moléculas que
estamos midiendo en moles con esta en
minúscula hay que escribir de nuevo que
un moles 6.0 22 por 10 a la 23
entonces simplemente estoy diciendo que
esta es una forma de escribir esta
fórmula
ok por la temperatura y si le arreglamos
esto tenemos que por ver es igual a
enero
rt ok es decir si yo conozco la presión
y el volumen y digamos el número de
moles y la temperatura
estas tres suponiendo que r es una
constante y que ya la conocemos que ya
les diré que es de hecho r es llamada la
constante universal de gas y es 8.31
jules
por por muy mal que el vino es decir
esto más o menos no te está diciendo qué
es lo que necesitamos en esta fórmula
verdad esto de aquí debe terminar en
jules
así que si tenemos esta presión en
pascales y volumen en metros cúbicos
vamos a terminar con jules aquí y esto
será en moles esto es 3 8.31 jules por
mol por kelvin y es la temperatura está
en que el vino honestamente si te
memoriza estas dos cosas en toda la
termodinámica probablemente podrás hacer
el 95% de los problemas así es como
funcionan simplemente p v / t
es decir si tú cambias la presión o el
volumen o la temperatura entonces
tendrás que hay aquí era un 1 que esta
proporción se conserva es decir esto es
igual a la presión por el volumen entre
la temperatura final ok también
necesitas memorizar esto que la presión
por el volumen es igual la nrc dónde
eres 8.31 jules por molde por kelvin ok
y quizás ya más o menos haya se
desarrolla un poquito de intuición de
esto pero lo veremos en el próximo vídeo
estas son las dos fórmulas esenciales
que hay que conocer en termodinámica y
que espero que podamos agarrar más
intuición de ello nos vemos